season three is the place to be so if
you not do the name then you not win it
[Music]
insecure fest was the place to be to get
the scoop on all things season three we
saw her she was telling Daniel she was
gonna sleep on his couch so we're gonna
pick up season three with just that I am
doing great I bet that girl motus our ex
crew the cast of insecure tells ET that
things need to pick up right where they
left off but the big question is where
does that leave Lauren here we go moment
of truth
are we gonna see him at some point in
the season
you know they had a great conversation
they closed that chapter pretty well so
we just want to really want to emulate
real life you know when you
what happened and I think you do what
you do when you break up with somebody
and there's closure and you're like hey
I'm trying to go on and you know still
live my life and do other things and I
think that's what you'll see this season
she wants to get Issa on track and she's
going to tell the truth
Kelly always tells the truth so we're
gonna see her help her a longer a look
right now you don't have enough money to
move out on your own if Daniel she knows
y'all were mad she got your tweets the
end of season two
winner was upset because our blood
pressure was high at the cliffhanger
with you and ro listen Twitter black
Twitter Latino Twitter all the Twitter's
were upset and we're just like oh why
butts bet white you have a character
who's coming off with a thing with drove
obviously we're you know I'm sort of
settling to some degree I'll take half
of the man rather than no man and so
we're trying to you know challenge that
this year is like what does that leave
her Molly it seems like she's about to
cut you off
art is ro prepared for this it's easy to
say you're gonna do that and then you
don't I think as far as being prepared
no I should be prepared really as a
model you know it's more so for her to
handle throw is married he has a home
and he'll be there regardless of what
happens with my Leandro you know what I
mean so I think it's for her to really
handle but you opened the door draw open
the door you were married so that should
be all completely off-limits but you
guys had a open marriage which that
seems to be a little questionable yeah
well like I said you're gonna get some
questions answered this season yeah yogi
you'll definitely get some confirmation
I believe
wait why I also saw Tiffany's pregnant
so that's a whole new dynamic we should
pregnancy has a tendency to sort of
change a friendship dynamic and change
an individual and so you're gonna see
our see what we do with that right
you're gonna we're gonna explore what it
means for this character in this season
of her life with these friends to be
pregnant
I think frosting was all about how do we
reinvent the show we just push the
envelope and that's what we try to do
this year and kind of shake up the whole
game in terms of what you think you
should expect for season three I'm gonna
bail them
[Applause]
you
[Music]